you
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
dumps
big massive dumps dumps
big massive dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
dumps dumps
[Music]
dumps dump big massive dumpsters
[Music]
toilets 10 times 15 times as opposed to
once
dumps dumps
[Music]
dumps dump big massive dumps gums dumps
dumps what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at that that is a proper wrecker
why who thinks he's smarter than you why
who thinks he's smarter than you why he
thinks he's smarter than you
this is just considered
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser
[Music]
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shock man
[Music]
jones has fake callers jones has fake
callers jones has fake callers jones has
fake callers
this is just a
this is just
corporate takeover censorship d banking
[Music]
tyranny look at that
look at that look at that corporate
takeover censorship d-banking arrest
tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
ten times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
[Music]
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
[Music]
elements
god bless
the united states thank you very much
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's going to
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
old motor cause pac-man's a loser
he's not a knight at the round table
that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
i was telling my children
you
[Music]
mangoes my bags are mangoes
i love mangoes too nine cents okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures like
three boxes
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
down
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying from the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
is
[Music]
all right welcome everybody so much to
discuss i'm so glad that you're here uh
the the news is not particularly good uh
and i'm gonna talk about chemical
weapons today we're going to talk about
the bombing of a maternity ward
it's not good it's not good but at least
we are here at least we are here a few
important
um
i guess we would call them announcements
i don't know how elements of
housekeeping
um first and foremost
i will probably be covering the trump
rally on saturday it's in south carolina
it is a it's sort of what we might call
a proper 2022 rally in that
in in theory
the rally is in support of 2022
candidates endorsed by donald trump
um
so
that is
um you know gonna be pretty interesting
i guess
and i will probably be covering it
depending on what i have uh going on
now there are people
asking me to cover a particular trump
interview
um
trump's doing an interview with a prank
channel is that true margin
yeah okay if someone can send what the
nelk boys i don't even know what that is
if so if anybody can i i was gonna look
at some clips from a new trump interview
but uh
the kneel if somebody can email info at
davidpakman.com with a link to whatever
this nelk boys thing it is
um
i i would consider looking at it okay so
programming note number one i may indeed
be covering the trump rally on saturday
and then secondly next week into the
following next friday i'm going to be
down in florida where i will appear on
anthony pompliano's best business show
that's going to be on friday
uh in florida and then on
uh tuesday in florida i will appear on
patrick bett david's
patrick bet david podcast
so that'll be tuesday
the following you know you guys you
understand so that's going to be that's
something very interesting to look
forward to and i think uh many of you
will enjoy it and then lastly i want to
mention
um that i will
be giving away so as some of you know
i have this gavel which we use to
adjudicate when people want to get
unbanned i'll say yes unbanned or not
and then that's what happens the thing
is broken
and so we are going to be giving this
away to a lucky twitch viewer
when we reach 100
000 twitch followers i don't know how
we're going to give it away we're going
to give it away to a follower somehow
but i don't exactly know how and just to
make it even cooler i'm going to take my
sharpie
and i will sign this thing i guess here
which is the the best area
there it is my signature
so at some point this thing will be
given away
where'd the cap go
oh it's on here hold on
uh yeah so i don't know how i know i
know when we're going to give it away
which is when we hit a hundred thousand
followers on twitch i don't yet know how
we're going to give it away if people
have ideas you can get in touch
um with a suggestion okay all right so
someone sent me the nelkie boys trump
interview and we'll look at that a
little bit later
okay let's start with really what the
major news is first and foremost
western officials are quote seriously
concerned that vladimir putin may use
chemical weapons now we've already
talked on the podcast today we talked
about tactical
uh battlefield nukes which are not like
you know what we saw in hiroshima or
nagasaki but rather
uh i guess i guess to some degree we
would call them like marginally less
destructive nukes so that's one concern
here's the other component of this
western officials see the prospect of
russia deploying non-conventional
weapons as a realistic possibility it
emerged today as ukraine accused putin
of targeting a maternity hospital
western officials have concerns
the uk prepares to send anti-aircraft
missiles to ukraine
now i have to tell you
i don't think
russia would target a children's and
maternity hospital i i don't i can't
think of any reason why they would
deliberately do that but the point is
that they're being careless enough
that they've hit a children's in
maternity hospital
that's
that's my opinion you know for what it's
worth and i'm glad for other people to
say no no here's why putin would target
a maternity hospital i i just don't
think i think it's there's an
indifference and there's a lack of
precision
but
i can't think of why it would be it
would be deliberate there's no real
advantage
uh and if you think oh well if you
target a maternity hospital ukrainians
will be so demoralized they'll just quit
resisting no uh it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't really make sense to me i'm not
defending putin i just think it's it's
out of ignorance i think there's random
shelling going on and it's just
absolutely and completely uh immoral
what they what they are doing um a
western official spoke on the condition
of anonymity and said we're seeing some
of the disinformation come out of moscow
about non-conventional weapons we saw
this in syria the russians starting that
talk when they or their proxies were
about to use those weapons there asked
if there are concerns that russia will
use chemical weapons they replied quote
we have good reason
to be concerned about the possible use
of non-conventional weapons
partly because we've seen what has
happened in other theaters for example
syria partly because we see a bit of
setting the scene for that
in the false flag claims that are coming
out so it's a serious concern for us
russian-backed syria was repeatedly
accused of using chemical weapons there
russia vetoed a 2017 u.n resolution
that would have looked into who was
responsible
uh the organization for the prohibition
of chemical weapons found people were
exposed to sarin gas in 2017
but did not identify who was responsible
so that's the concern there
here's a report about the maternity
hospital
associated press report
strike hits ukraine maternity hospital
17 reported hurt
a russian airstrike devastated a
maternity hospital wednesday
amid growing warnings from the west that
moscow's invasion is about to take a
more brutal and indiscriminate turn
ukrainian officials say at least 17 were
wounded in the attack
so
that's a real
problem
and then
this is daily mail so you know take it
for what it's worth
biden sends two patriot missile
batteries to poland after calling
planned to send all their mig-29 jets to
ukraine unworkable
vice president harris will arrive in
warsaw today
as hand-to-hand combat breaks out in the
kiev
suburbs which is
that is something
and then stalled and frustrated putin
will likely double down in the coming
weeks per the cia now of course the cia
sometimes gets things wrong that's for
sure
but so far i mean listen if you you know
you go back a couple weeks now even
months
uh intel says ukraine is massing troops
at the i'm sorry russia's massing troops
at the ukrainian border
you've got you know
a certain contingent of people saying
it's literally not happening no it is
the intel was right
putin plans to invade no they say
putin's never going to invade
uh and then he does well he's not going
to go further it's never going to get to
kiev
and then it does
and uh you know on on this it's not just
the cia
uh and for people talking it's it's
other countries intel as well and you
know i i don't i don't care about the
cia the cia's sometimes correct and it's
sometimes horribly incorrect
it's not about oh we we you know we
always trust x and distrust y
but for people talking about
the
false case for war in iraq made in 2003
circumstances
are very different
um and in addition
a lot of the evidence is just publicly
available it's not based on
interpretations of the evidence so for
people saying it's it's just like when
we could trust them on the iraq no it's
not
it's nothing like that
so those are all concerns that we're
following
um
ukraine maternity hospital bombed by
russian forces pure genocide
some are calling it we already talked
about the details of that bombing
uh russia using thermobaric rockets
which rupture lungs in ukraine
confirms the ministry of defense
um again
this is the mirror
another media outlet that i i you know
want to say let's verify
but increasingly widespread reports
about that
so
these are all the different things that
are going on
and uh many of them are
extraordinarily disturbing
um
okay
let's see what else we've got here super
chats did we ban gold from russia we
didn't ban gold but apparently they
might ban men and we will ban men right
um
okay
let me say thank you to a few people
those people are elevated disc golf
fairy tigers sparkliest socialist who
has both gifted a subscription and
subscribed
twisted lover and brankle brandleby six
people getting some beautiful twitch
prime subscriptions also i want to say a
big thank you to andrew martin andrew's
the first person today to sign up on my
website joinpakman.com and his new
member number seven i very much
appreciate that robert says break russia
economically and militarily
demilitarize russia or this will happen
again but worse that's robert's opinion
from sweden i believe
also thank you to magic turtle and
a-c-a-z
for the twitch uh twitch prime
subscriptions thank you very much
everybody all right let's get into some
other things
uh let me see where to even start
oh okay
here's a farcical clip this is eric
balling
from uh
i guess this is he's on newsmax yeah he
says the entire
russian invasion of ukraine
is the fault of kamala harris
that's quite a big brain hot take but
now she's been to europe twice
in all seriousness because this is a
very serious situation kamala harris is
going to stop world war three joe biden
has sent her in she's the one think
about that for a second folks biden made
her borders are to try and stop the
border crisis and it only got worse and
worse what russia and china are seeing
right now is disorganization a
disorganized nato lacking in common
ground and even in communication and
putin is watching very closely looking
for weakness and sending in one kamala
harris only exposes just how weak and
poor our decision-making processes are a
reminder that the last time kamala went
to europe she gave a speech about how
ukraine should join nato and russia
four days later
invaded ukraine
that's a very very dumb
take i have to tell you
uh
i it's almost like the opposite of what
he's saying is true
um yeah this yeah eric balling is sort
of like a low rent um let me think who
is he like a low rent of
i don't even know there's really no
equivalent to balling
it's not it's not like a tucker
it's not like a jesse waters
a low rent jim lair no no no but it's
got to be like a low rent version of
another right winger
i don't know he's a low rent you know
eric balling's a low-rent version of
himself when he was on fox news
it's just him but just on newsmax which
is you know marginally marginally more
depressing i guess uh okay so that's his
opinion
here is an
anti-mask activist imagine being an
activist against cloth
anti-mask activist says eminem's
packaging is blasphemy which could lead
you to hell
this i have to say
let's take a look here
oh here we go with another big
corporation company making fun of our
lord and savior jesus christ there's
nothing new under the sun they love to
mock jesus and you know how i know that
he's the one true god because they never
mock any other god never hear them
saying anything about buddha never hear
them saying anything about allah if
everybody was mocking zeus
by this explanation i would have no
choice but to believe zeus
is the one true god there's always jesus
there's literally a dove ascending right
above his head right here in this image
it is disgusting it is blasphemy but
this is what they like to do you want to
know how i know that god is the truth
check this out this is what the lord
just revealed to me think about when you
are in the truth when it comes to things
that are going on in the world right
with the news what does the false
prophet media do listen if you think
eminems are demonic i've got a i i've
got a uh i've got to explain to you
something about a snickers bar golf
statue makes fun of you makes you think
that you're wrong right tells you that
you're not in the truth but really you
are in the truth and then when you're
following the lies they cheer you on and
they're all for it it's the same thing
with jesus they mock they make fun of
why because they know that they can lead
you on a road down to hell if they can
make you believe that it's not true oh
here we go do you guys understand what
she's talking about
like i have no idea what she's talking
about
there's a dove in the image and so it's
it's mocking jesus does anybody know
what you're talking about what she's
talking about
nobody yeah i i just have no idea
it's a religious rant of some kind i
guess
but i don't know
it's extraordinarily disturbing yeah i
want to say thanks to andre bavaria who
just made a twitch prime sub and says
what do you think will happen to putin
after the war obviously relations to
russia under putin can't go back to
normal when this is over do you think
putin is done no matter how the war ends
no i don't think putin is done no matter
how the war ends but i think there is a
chance putin ends up dead
but i don't think it's a guarantee that
putin is done i know scaramucci was
saying that putin's done for
but i'm just not sure
pepe says she's listening to the
assassin's creed theme
um and wander says this is what the lord
revealed to me lady try dmt and then we
can talk keep up the keep up the good
work david yes thank you
uh very very appropriate uh take there
uh okay here's peter ducey today
i guess very confused about how oil
pipelines work continuing to talk about
keystone xl let's listen because there's
a lot of gray area here it is a restart
of the keystone xl construction
completely off the table as long as joe
biden is president well why don't you
tell me what that would help address
i'm asking you if it is an option you
guys say all options are on the table is
restarting keystone construction one of
them if we're trying to bring about more
supply that does not address any problem
it's supply from canada a friendly ally
instead of saudi arabia that's already
that's we're already getting that oil
peter it's the the pipeline is just a
delivery mechanism it is not an oil
field so it does not provide more supply
into the system it does not adjust
stable is it possible that joe biden
will ever
say
you guys can go ahead with construction
of keystone xl there's no plans for that
and it would not address any of the
problems we're having currently i'm
going to ask you guys something and i
want people in the chat to really be
honest with me about this okay
um
i'm gonna tell you something about
keystone xl and i just want you guys to
say in the chat
i knew that or i didn't know that okay
when they talk about keystone xl being
stopped
okay
keystone xl pipeline phase 1
phase 2 and phase 3
are already functioning
when they talk about keystone xl they're
actually talking about
phase 4 but the the pipeline is already
there and it's already delivering oil to
i forget the states i think it's like
oklahoma
you know this is music did did you guys
know that or not know that like in other
words i think a lot of people believe
there is no keystone xl pipeline and
that
the product
all of it has been stopped
most people did not know that right
right for the amount that the right
talks about keystone xl
it's not even mentioned that the
pipeline's up and running what has been
stopped is phase four and now this part
i'm less sure about you guys can tell me
i believe part of the controversy about
phase four is that it it would go
through some indigenous land and there
was a um
there was a conflict and a disagreement
about that is am i recalling that
correctly that part of this is about the
indigenous land that phase four would go
through it's like a slightly wider
pipeline
that that also applies to okay
most people seem to think that's what it
is yeah anyway so
and so so there's two things here first
of all keystone xl is up and running
it's just phase four that has been
stopped but more importantly
we are in a gas price crisis today today
it would take years to do phase four of
keystone xl at least a year like most
most most
optimistically the idea that that would
solve anything to restart that
construction today is just completely
absurd
um
people like ducey want to spread the
idea that biden
overnight could drop gas prices by
saying start construction of what is one
of four phases of keystone xl it's crazy
it's crazy guys it's it's completely
absurd
um
okay
let's uh
let's continue with the with some other
stuff here oh
let's look at this i think some of you
will find this funny so i know that many
of you missed yesterday's ama i did an
ama on the politics discord which has
about 62 000 um subscribers and they
were all pretty normal calls
until the last two and we're gonna clip
these and separate them out but just for
people who missed these yesterday the
these were pretty funny
gonna be respectful david's time uh arab
what's your name arab uh love russia i
think your name is uh you're next
whenever you're ready sir yes so like i
noticed that a lot of your content is
based on like trump january 6 like
marjorie taylor green i'm wondering like
why don't you focus on like real
politics instead of like like this weird
like trump stuff
okay what's a topic you'd like me to
cover
uh you should cover like the fight for
medicare for all the fight for labor
instead of like oh trumpers said this or
like that anti-vaxxers scream in a
walmart
well we cover all of those i do know
exactly what you're saying i appreciate
the question um we do cover all of those
things and uh i absolutely love the
feedback
all right well let me give you a
challenge before i go can you talk can
you not make a video about trump for
like one week just one week
what's the point of the challenge
just to see if you can do it just to see
if you cannot talk about trump for a
week and what would that what would that
prove
i don't know i mean if you look at your
channel every single day it's like trump
investigation or january 6 committee
it's like why don't you just do one week
where it's like i'm not gonna talk about
trump i'm gonna restrain from trump's
stuff and i'm gonna go to other things
okay and and if i do that then then what
would we prove or achieve
uh like the whole politics world is
gonna like change everything's gonna
change just based on my youtube channel
yeah wow that's really some i should
think i didn't i that's that's a lot of
power i mean when you think about it
that way that's really a lot of power
yeah i i
i gotta say i sincerely regret you've
been one of the last questions
um
[Laughter]
last question and the last one's the
wackiest this is a historic phone call
this next one and we will
scribbles
um scribbles if you're ready go for it
hi
here i'm just gonna step up i'll be
right back i'm sorry i'm getting my
nails done um i just wanted hold on a
second you're at a nail salon right now
yeah and i feel bad they're picking up
my color for me and i totally just left
them i'm sorry we went back one second
oh my god um what is that like acrylic
or something
um yeah i'm getting my tips redone
actually sorry you're getting what
redone
my tips oh my god oh my god okay holy
[ __ ] that's acrylic but they're gel
right yeah you don't want them to chip
right like no chips oh my god anyways
okay hey okay first comment real quick
i'm fine okay i'm dina first comment
your voice is way deeper on these falls
like on your youtube channel i don't
know why is that weird okay second
comment i kind of want to pick your
brain about hate speech right because
okay so i feel like i'm kind of like a
moral fear like okay so like i'm not a
moral relative when it comes to hate
speech right because i still think those
objective things when it comes to like
something should not be crossed when it
comes to hate speech but like i was
playing this call for people all night
yesterday oh so i get okay so like i'm
palestinian so like i get when it comes
to a point where like bds obviously is
like totally slandered in like american
media was like oh it's a tourist
organization almost bs right but also
there's some things that literally just
should not be crossed in i think like
um a civil speech right so i just
segmented your view and like what you
perceive as hate speech and like if you
do think that any speech should be
allowed like if you're like a free
speech like absolutist you know what i
mean
i am not wow that's a lot there you're
you're shot out of a cannon today i have
to say oh no absolutely not let's see
how i totally talk i'm actually talking
really slow right now because i don't
want people here to think i'm on crack
okay you know what i mean with love and
peace sorry okay just go up you're
talking slow right now you're saying
yeah absolutely oh well good listen um i
am
close to a free speech absolutist now
hold on a second are you at in what
context are you just saying like on
twitter or what or if i had my own
platform or what are you or the
government what do you mean
okay so like
okay so i get the whole platform debates
like oh i own twitter so i could say
that's right but when i people say that
i reply twitter is definitely now public
space to be honest right but okay let's
just do the government context because
like if we went into the whole twitter
debate that'll be a whole other
conversation right so we'll just do
government debates right now right um
like if we're in a public space like
debating on protesting right
yeah how free should it be right because
like um i know there's this whole like
content versus
time and space but like the government
can obviously use time and space even
when they just want to do content just
to be like oh we just we're just we're
just putting the we're just putting a uh
like we're just putting a curfew because
you know we want to exploit the public
but it's actually because they want to
you know limit the alarm protests right
time and space that's interesting now
are you talking
metaphysically like are we talking about
the government could even bend space
time to its advantage no no no no i'm
talking about like you know how they
could do curfew was um like um if you're
talking about it like if you're taking
it to court and stuff you can be like oh
my god i know you're doing i sound
stupid you know what i mean like curfew
was right um because after almost once
in two so like during the
the protest that whole that led to the
like what says his name or whatever his
name is um
you know what i'm talking about right
are you talking about
what
were are you talking about
kyle rittenhouse
yeah but the reason why i call in
household thing was they shouldn't have
been out in the first place because
there was curfew laws and they put the
curfews laws because of they were saying
oh they want the safety of the public
but really if you're going to talk about
the court they're actually doing it
because of the alarm that goes the
content not the time um reasoning you
know what i mean
i actually don't know where you mean
where is your accent from are you are
you from new york
no it's from wisconsin
wisconsin i've i that's a very unusual
accent
no like do you want to okay like okay so
i just took i took a class on this
that's why i know because i was gonna be
a lawyer and how to come into breakdown
right so i took an undergrad about this
right um like so the police name if you
take us to court right there's two like
um there's like strict perception of it
and then there's like non-strip
perception of or like whatever i'm like
what i'm showing no sometimes i'm gonna
let this alone right now um so like the
time thing is like
we're going to um not allow protest
because of the timing versus we're not
going to protest because we don't like
the content of what you're protesting
right yeah
guys we're this is not sped up i have to
people are like put slow it down to one
next this is not sped up the government
says we're going to not allow it because
of the
time because it's too late and they use
that a lot though when it's the camera
they don't like either but they can get
away with it because of the timing do
you get what i mean you're not from long
island are you serious i'm like what
but like i just wanted i want to pick
your brain about hate speech right
yes i i will go with you you want to
pick my brain about hate speech that
part i understand we've not gotten
anywhere further than that so
listen it sounds like a lot is going on
um i can't tell you how much i
appreciate the call i hope that the
manicure
goes well what's a manicure cost in
wisconsin anyway okay oh my god okay
there were dry undercovers like
literally sixty dollars but it's only
forty dollars now because of it because
it's just a regal so it's fine
i'm sorry i'd wha what is it how much
does it cost
it was 60 dollars for the original one
because i get a particular shape right i
get an almond with a round tip because i
hate square like square shaped manicures
look like really abrasive and really
like masculine to me and i [ __ ] hate
it right so if you want something really
sweet if you like have a girl in your
life just tell us
yeah
can you just tell me where you're really
from like
that
you're not from long island
no
well
well listen um thank you so much i can't
think of a better note on which we would
no i don't even know what the question
is you want to pick my brain about hate
speech i don't even know what that means
i mean i don't know oh my god okay i
mean i'm not gonna say thank you but
all right well
anyway so that's a pretty historic phone
call i don't know that we've ever really
had anything like that on the uh
anywhere anywhere quite frankly
i want to say thank you to bad circuits
and mr vister for the twitch prime
subscriptions uh um uh oh well yeah okay
i will do a free
coffee mug
for whoever first uses please don't war
or obama
as a coupon code on my website okay
first person at joinpakman.com to get a
membership using either the code please
don't war
or obama
i will send you a coffee mug anywhere in
the world that has sort of like normal
you know postal service and stuff like
that uh okay i have so much more to get
to so i'm going to continue gesh make
via super chat said peter ducey's
insipid questions are extremely lacking
in anything that appeals to a cerebrally
active audience i think his tenure will
be a long one on the fox propaganda
network thank you sir yes thank you sir
sir sure
okay
let's get to these new
um trump clips trump did an interview
with ronna mcdaniel
and
it's a crazy interview let's just look
at some of these clips thank you for
what you're doing thank you for being
out there i just have two fun things i
wanna say to you these are gonna be fun
guys are we ready for some fun
it's gonna get fun now
one
you're such a wonderful person you've
been so great to women
haven't 46 women accused him of anything
ranging from harassment to assault
[Laughter]
wow that's really fun guys she was right
she was right i mean that was really
really fun
uh okay let's go to the next
clip dur and you saved hundreds of
thousands if not millions of lives with
that well you know we had in 1917 100
million people died i think we would
have had the same thing so now
understand that
it was 1918. oh hey everybody coming
over from jeff waldorf's twitch stream
uh we are checking out a new trump
interview
he keeps saying 1917.
it was the 1918 flu
and
he's slurring very badly yeah i know
and you saved hundreds of thousands if
not millions of lives with that well you
know we had in 1917 100 million people
died i think we would have had the same
thing so we did something that was
incredible we did it in less than nine
months and it was supposed to take
anywhere from five to 12 years how many
lies are in this 17 second clip
okay i'm gonna actually let let me let
me really
do this justice
because i think this could be a record
for lies and he's only talking for a few
of the seconds let let's really go lie
by lie sure and you saved hundreds of
thousands if not millions of lives with
that well you know we had in 1917 okay
so it wasn't 1918. i'm sorry it wasn't
1917 it was 1918. so that's the
misstatement or lie number one let's
continue 100 million people died i think
we would have the same thing so okay
there is no serious estimate
about 100 million people dying of covet
i've i have not seen that so he's wrong
about that
we did something that was incredible we
did it in less than nine months and it
was supposed to take anywhere from five
to 12 years okay so five to twelve years
yeah so that's not true what trump is
referring to is that
before mrna do people know this before
mrna technology if you're just building
or developing or creating a one-off
vaccine from scratch
it can take five to twelve years
the whole point of mrna technology which
has been in development for over a
decade is you have the platform ready to
go
and then you can quickly sequence the
virus and create the vaccine so it has
no so so i guess that's lie number three
and really lie number four
is that trump did anything trump didn't
do anything he agreed to pre-purchase
vaccines that's all that's all trump did
he didn't do anything about developing
it so i guess four
lies
in
he starts talking at five seconds so
four lies in 12 seconds guys that's like
you know that's
it's rapid fire lies
um
it's all very very dishonest it really
is
i want to say thank you to samuel partou
who just signed up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
obama
samuel you have won a free david pakman
show coffee mug please email info
davidpakman.com
to uh tell us where to send it also
thank you and welcome to vagabond soul
mz frazzled and kafkaesque
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 15. i really appreciate
that
very very much so let's continue here
there was never anybody tougher on
russia than i was
[Laughter]
there's line number one i guess i mean
that one uh we're
uh
that's a good one huh and i would say
that putin would if he was being honest
he would say that uh
no no no no putin would not say trump
was really tough on me that's not
something putin would say seven seconds
in two lies sanctions i put on i was the
one that ended nordstrom exactly there
was never anybody even close i mean not
stream to them nordstrom 2 was the
biggest thing nobody ever even heard of
it until i came along complete
losing nordstrom 2
is not the worst thing that's ever
happened to russia
even as is noted here 27 million people
died in the soviet union during world
war ii
nor what trump did to nordstream 2 is
not the worst thing that's ever happened
to russia explained and then i shut it
down
and there was never anything so big that
happened to russia shutting down
nordstrom 2. yeah that's so that's
that's very very much not true
obama prompt asked whether that caller
was whitney now we're going to hear from
whitney in a little bit let's not get
ahead of ourselves we have a lot of time
here to go
uh okay here's another
bit another breadcrumb of this bizarre
interview i think that's actually a big
reason why the problem you have with
ukraine i think when putin and washi and
when kim jong-un and when the iranians
are watching that the iranian leaders
i think they saw what happened in
afghanistan and i think that gave them
a new sense of power and dignity
they got dignity from when biden left
afghanistan what is he talking about
does anybody know what that means there
was a sense of dignity experienced by
president xi
when biden left afghanistan what does
that even mean
i i just don't get it
nobody okay you guys are as confused as
i am fair fair fair fair
thanks to captain flash heart for the
twitch prime i appreciate that all right
let's now go to the much requested oh
wait this wasn't it that's some kind of
ufc thing
wait a second where is this
maz vidal no hold on someone emailed it
to me there's another trump interview
here
that we wanted to look at
here it is let's see what this is all
about
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i have no idea what channel or show this
even is today's amazing huh
we're gonna make uh history today boys
which is pretty crazy
rock shorts for sure
throwing the sweats for the prezi
former president
is this a cringe stream you gotta think
of all the people that are gonna watch
this interview well that's why because
he hasn't spoken on this issue yet all
right i guess they talked to trump
all right great so yeah we'll go for it
we're at uh we're at mar-a-lago i can't
even believe this is happening we got
donald trump
president of the united states
honorable applause round of applause
thank you applause thank you we're
really really excited to be doing this
it's my honor my honor you come highly
recommended by dana white and that's
good enough for me so what
it's already genius a full group of
people i guess you're friends of his and
uh
ufc thing
and uh he's done an incredible job and
he when he said that i've been with dana
for a long time he's been my friend for
a long time with him and uh i said
that's good enough for me but you do
you've done a great job we've become
such good friends with dana we've always
been fans of the ufc but
kind of met him through his son was a
big fan of our of our content so
it's been a blessing to be able to be
friends with dana white he's such a good
guy yes he does i tell you i don't know
what would happen with ufc without him
that's one man they say uh
you can always replace somebody i'm not
sure if that man is replaceable
definitely not he's safe i know what's
the what's the ufc gonna be like when
dana's gone well he'll be there for a
long time so we're not gonna have to
worry about that right don't you think i
expected you to be rolling in here with
no suit on coming off the golf course i
was expecting are you always
rocking this no i'm i'm a worker i work
hard at work
oh this is this is this is too much
this is too much i can't tell if is any
is are they trolling him
or are they for real i don't even
understand what's happening here
this is perplexing
work long hours i work hard i see what's
going on with our country right now it's
never been in a position like this
now we're going to get oil i hear from
venezuela and iran
now think of this and russia
uh if you would talk about biden banned
russian imports of oil and when is this
from
this is from
what's the date here
uh
[Music]
i
the date's not showing for some am i
missing what did when this was uploaded
weird i guess can you are you even able
to hide that i've never seen that hidden
on youtube all right told me that just a
short while ago we had oil at 30 a
barrel and even less and now we're up to
you see what's happening today you guys
probably haven't because you've been
sitting here for a half an hour but uh
if you were watching every
every 10 minutes is going it's like it's
like a rocket ship going up
and that's costing the world it's cost
it's also fueling russia
but it's costing the world the energy is
never gone it just broke a record an
all-time record why is this guy grinning
like a doofus who are these guys
per barrel and there's never been
anything like this and we had it down to
30 a barrel and now of course that had
nothing to do with trump i mean there
was a demand collapse when planes
stopped flying and cars stopped driving
um and of course now we have a global
situation i mean this just hasn't it has
almost nothing to do with trump nor
biden really even less in a sense we had
a fight to keep it up because we had so
much of it we were going to be uh twice
as big as russia and saudi arabia
combined
saudi arabia and that would have taken
place in a very short while we were
already energy independent
and we were already became number one
and now they cut way back and it's all
for
the environment and we had the cleanest
air in the cleanest water yet recorded
during my last year
surrounded by
water big water ocean water so it's uh
what's happening now is horrible what's
happening in ukraine
is uh it's genocide it's
nobody's ever seen anything like it and
because of modern technology two weeks
ago it was savvy energy and the cell
phones and everything you get to see
all of this all of these atrocities
you're seeing them
on tape on television nobody's ever seen
anything like this
so would you blame the gas prices is
that because of this conflict in ukraine
or is it like a combo of things no i
don't i think it's because of that a
little bit but uh we right now would
have been if we left our policies in
place we would have been able to supply
the world with energy and what is he
talking about i mean
this
what what is he talking about
how
how can anyone with all of the
discussion about gas prices at this
point not just understand what's going
on
and
you probably wouldn't have a war for a
lot of reasons number one putin would
not have done it he would not have done
it
this would never have taken place
if what what is he saying now it
wouldn't have taken place if what uh if
you
had a person that did very well in the
election i'm being very nice when i say
that too i'm being very kind oh he's
saying if he was president we did
phenomenally in the election 12 million
more votes than we got
yeah but biden got eight million more
than you uh the previous time
uh if the election if we were running if
you had the trump administration in
there there would be no war number one
it's not even clear the people asking
the questions have any idea what's going
on like it's not clear anybody knows
what's going on sometimes trump is like
just saying nonsense gobbledygook
but the interviewers at least have some
sense of what he's
wrong about or like what he's even
saying incorrectly
the interviewers like one guy one guy is
just grinning and drinking a beer and
seems to have no clue what's even being
discussed yeah and number two
uh energy prices would have been down
war or no war
they would have been very low because we
were dominant we were becoming i call it
energy dominance we were dominant in
energy
and getting more so by the day well why
wouldn't why wouldn't there been a war
because you were in office no because i
understood putin i talked to putin i
spoke to him about ukraine
it there wouldn't
there would not
not have been a war because he was in
office
there would not have been a war because
he
knew putin and i said don't do it and i
won't go into the exact conversation but
uh under certain uh
if certain people asked i'll tell them
exactly what the conversation was not
the not if you schlubs ask but if other
people ask i'll tell them what happened
but we look weak we look stupid
we look like we don't know what we're
doing so did he explain why there would
not have been war if he was president
i'm not even understanding the answer
i start to question my own
english comprehension when i see this
and like
i hear words coming out of trump's mouth
and there's people around him listening
and it's not obvious that they don't get
it even though they obviously so i i
start wondering like do i just not
understand english well enough is that
the problem is is it my problem here and
nobody's ever seen the country like this
and
let me tell you it really began
not only with a horrible weak border but
it really began when they
so incompetently withdrew
from afghanistan i got it down to 2 000
soldiers we were going to
withdraw but we weren't leaving 85
billion dollars worth of equipment we
weren't leaving
dead soldiers and i spoke to the taliban
the leader abdul i thought it so
remember guys when trump says i spoke to
abdul he used to say i spoke to muhammad
and now now the story is i spoke to
abdul my guess is he doesn't know who he
spoke to and i said don't ever kill any
of our soldiers don't ever kill one more
soldier we're going to hit you harder
than you've ever been hit before
and we went 18 months without a soldier
being killed without an american being
think of it without an american being
killed in afghanistan
not democrat run chicago or man what's
what's
disappointing is
these guys are in so over their heads
because they they don't even understand
the degree to which everything coming
out of trump's mouth is a lie
but they're completely ill-equipped or
uninterested
in even
contesting any of it new york but in
afghanistan
and 18 months and then
they did this withdrawal
which after 21 years was the right thing
to do
but we were doing it that's why we were
down to 2 000 soldiers but so it was the
right thing to do okay so incompetently
handled between the death and the 85
billion dollars they have better
equipment than almost any country in the
world and
now afghanistan is one of the largest
seller of arms anywhere in the world
because they're selling it i'll just say
afghanistan seems like it's overlooked
at times right now like people forget
about what's actually what is actually
the current state of afghanistan yeah
people are forget what what a great
question
people people aren't talking enough
about afghanistan huh mr president sir i
know well i hear it's a mess uh trump
doesn't know either i mean nobody i
guess i guess nobody cares we're sending
a lot of money to afghanistan if you can
believe this uh they're asking for money
and we're sending it they have 700 000
machine guns guns rifles of all types
they're selling a lot of them they don't
need that many they don't have there's
no way they can use what we left they
have helicopters they have planes how is
this a ufc podcast like how on earth did
trump end up in this situation it's
it's it's all uh i don't know who's
interviewing him i have no idea someone
said it's the the pelky boys
what are these guys named helky
jelky
nelkey
okay it's the nelkie boys trains they're
selling equipment to other countries
they're giving equipment
to china and to russia because they're
going to re-engineer de-engineer they're
going to come back
with a helicopter just like our great
helicopter we have the greatest
helicopters in the world they now have
them and they're going to duplicate them
afghanistan was i think
the most embarrassing
moment hold on here's someone dean hill
says the nelk dudes are from toronto
they do youtube prank videos party
videos etc they now have a huge frat boy
following in the united states okay so
that's who is interviewing trump steve
our country the way we got out
we looked like we were surrendering
which in a sense i guess they were
to take the soldiers out before you take
the american
people out american citizens are over
there right now trying to get out they
can't
uh but to take the soldiers out first
instead of last first you take the
people then you may take some people
from afghanistan
these guys seem bored these guys seem
completely bored with the interview
the guy looked completely lost
as to what's even going on
it's not clear who's more ill-equipped
for this conversation
is is it trump or is it the guys
interviewing him
um
is this one of the prank videos i think
is a fair question like is this the
prank
that they're doing oh i'm sorry thank
you to denmark ireman for the gift uh
two gifts actually putting us at 19. i
really appreciate that guys also huge
thank you to christian tully
who just got a membership on my website
using the coupon code obama
i very much appreciate that let's
continue with this but i'm not i'm not
missing people supporting uh supporting
our stream today let's continue not
hundreds of thousands we have no idea
who we took out we have no idea who we
took out
but we take the people and we you don't
typically see gatorade at interviews
with trump take all the equipment and i
said i don't want to leave
a screw a nut a bolt well you left a nut
i won everything what about the hangers
sir take them out
sir sir congratulations sir you just won
the election mr president president sir
you can't answer that question you're on
the cover
yeah
leather and plastic hangers with steel
i said you take them out you take
everything out what does that mean take
them out though take them out take them
out of the country what you do is you
take them you take your equipment out we
left
thousands and thousands what does that
mean though what does that mean
thousands of pairs of night goggles
never even unpacked brand new better
than what we have the latest model
all of the i understand seven
seventy thousand
think of this because who has anything
70 000 trucks and vehicles 70 000
there's no company in this country that
has that many and a lot of them
i can't tell if this guy's laughing
because he realizes how stupid
everything like why why do we think this
guy's laughing is he like it's funny
that we even got the president here is
he so in awe and in love of trump is he
laughing because he knows it's all lies
like why is this particular guy grinning
like a doofus the entire time
because of the absurdity yeah i don't
know
summer armor played it unbelievably
expensive like you know 10 times the
cost of a vehicle itself
70 000 vehicles we left there trucks and
other vehicles
uh and i i tell you so putin was
watching
we were all watching you guys were
watching and the level of incompetence
and it looked like we ran the airport
the riot the bombs going off killing our
soldiers 13 killed but many badly
wounded you know they don't talk about
the ones with no egg legs and with no
arms and
as bad as that and worse
in a sense i mean some of
our soldiers were so badly
wounded hurt
nobody talks about that we talk about
the 13 dead
we talk about the
unbelievable incompetence that that
period that short period of time had but
i believe that that was the beginning
because putin would have never done it
with me he would is never going to take
over right ukraine do you ever talk to
putin's though no i haven't spoken to
him uh since but uh he was never ever
going to certainly under the trump
administration and i say zero chance i
don't say like i don't think
zero chance he would have done it and i
spoke to him about it
zero chance he would have done it right
but he saw yeah he saw the weakness he
saw afghanistan that the way the
incompetence of the withdrawal the way
they did it
was so bad who advised them to take
soldiers out first and leave people
behind
and the soldiers were in no danger we
had again not one soldier was killed in
18 months american soldier
and
when they saw the incompetence they grew
up we're kind of just retreading over
the same ground here he's repeating the
same
stuff over and over again of thanks to
skittle stew for gifting five
subscriptions on twitch i appreciate
that confidence of that i believe that
uh putin
was became
a different man when he saw that he
viewed the united states differently he
no longer respected the united states i
believe that president xi of china
became a different man they saw that too
and they see the borders that are open
they see all of the horrible things that
are happening at the border we're
millions all right i mean let's skip
ahead a little bit because this is an
hour long he's just repeating the same
stuff let's see if they hit a different
topic here
arizona that was some rally huh so we
are on youtube
i tell you your people are pretty loyal
like we it's pretty amazing trump
rallies are lit trump rallies are pretty
insane so we had a rally in texas the
other day 87 000 people that's not true
right didn't we watch that wasn't it
like 5
wasn't it five thousand people let me
let's see if we can actually find uh
okay donald trump texas rally
was that i think was that february or
was that does anybody remember was that
february or january
february
attendance let me see here
um
the reports say thousands not 87 000.
let me see if i can get an exact count
uh
not seeing the exact number 87 000
people
um yeah every report says thousands and
you i mean
we covered that it looked like between
five and seven thousand or something
like that yeah eighty-seven thousand
people what does that even mean
and plenty of people couldn't get in
they just couldn't get in too many
people they called it stampede i spoke
to the sheriff who's great can you let
those people get in thousands and
thousands couldn't get in he said
certainly
you think of cattle right with the staff
87 000 people 87 000 people donald we
had in alabama donald wow very very
formal informal here han donald 63 000
people
uh wherever we go we have
you know literally 50 60 why is that guy
laughing people know
we have more people now than i wonder if
that guy that guy might be i'm starting
to think the guy laughing is the
smartest guy in the room he may be
realizing how these are all literally
lies that that may be the one guy who
understands what's happening i'm now
starting to think before the election
it's been amazing there's anger
there's distrust they know the election
was rigged it was a totally rigged
election like a third world country and
they're angry about it um they're angry
about a lot of things they're going to
be really angry when they start paying
three times more for their gasoline but
the question is don are you coming i
mean i don't need to ask to tell you i
think yeah don what what is with these
guys huh you've hinted at it are you
coming back and gonna run for president
united states well you know the campaign
finance laws don't really allow you
to discuss that unless you're
going to literally go through a
different process
so i think a lot of people are going to
be really happy done this might be
really happy but we're going to be i
think a lot of people
are going to be very happy but i'll how
so i'll after well i'll wait till i have
so many people wanting me to do it i
think really that a lot of people are
going to be very happy they are very
unhappy right now look
they're you're saying it's going to
triple quadruple yeah it's go it's going
to levels a friend of mine said the
other day who's who's got money he said
i just paid three times more for
gasoline than i've been paying for the
last
three years and he said what are people
going to do
he couldn't believe it he goes to the
pump and he
the gas prices right now are a problem i
mean i don't who's going to deny that
it's just it's it barely has anything to
do with joe biden or donald trump and
i've said that for so long you know gets
a bill you know he gets a bill for
exiles for years
and it's fine and all of a sudden it's
three times higher does trump know how
people buy gas he's ever 60
people
well they just announced that it's now
over seven dollars and it's over five
dollars in many places and
it was a dollar eighty seven i had it
down to a dollar eighty seven and even
less than that during a certain period
of time
and
the
that those aren't the real numbers see
this this guy's laughter i feel like is
a knowing laughter increasingly i'm
thinking this guy knows what's up the
cost for a barrel
was down to 30 and even less than that
we skipped ahead a half for 20 minutes
they're still talking about gas so let's
let's skip ahead again and see what else
what other ground they cover
it wasn't a call we we got through
people
a meeting was set up in singapore
and then in vietnam we had two meetings
but we didn't have the problem that the
democrats would have had they would have
had a nuclear war with north korea i
have no doubt about it there is
absolutely
you can never say no chance but there is
no serious chance
that if hillary clinton had won
we would have been engaged in a nuclear
war with north korea that's
extraordinarily stupid i want to say
thank you to lynn eddington lynn just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code obama
also want to say thank you to
uh
i guess no one bw rock says these guys
look like they're doing a southwest
commercial
i think the real story is these guys
were eric trump's frat brothers at penn
is that that can't be true
guarantee trump has never pumped his own
gas i don't even know that trump drives
kim jong-un wanted nothing to do with
him it this was
look this is years now
we would have had a nuclear war
with north korea who who's coughing back
there are you okay is that your crew
that's uh that's the media will say
trump's coughing there must be something
wrong with him
we're going around
a little bit laid back
we run a pretty laid back thing we're
all good we're all good let's continue
on but let's let me just say we would
have had war with north korea north
korea is a major nuclear power
but i hate hearing biden say
no we don't want anything to do with
russia they're a nuclear power but so
are we
and we're bigger nuclear power and we
have brand new because of me
nuclear weapons that we didn't have and
we have renovated weapons that were very
old is that true trump had weapons
renovated do you guys know about that
i understand they put in hardwood
flooring
and now they're renovated and we never
want to use them and by the way you know
how you're not going to use them by
having them if you didn't have them
we would have big problems right but we
have them but biden shouldn't be talking
the way he's talking
because he's playing right into
he's playing right into putin's hands
putin
i've never heard this from a leader
outside of kim jong-un i guess to a
large extent but putin now talks about
his nuclear capability all the time yeah
he said this is a
you do the no-fly zone you do this we're
a nuclear country
and biden's saying they're a nuclear
country
it's so weak it's sending such a bad but
you have a no flight i have to say this
the
the bombing of these cities
indiscriminately the bombing of these
cities and the killing of all these
people
is a tragedy it's bad yes wow we've we
have a point of agreement
the bombing and the killing is bad i'll
i'll tell you i agree with trump on that
says this is a tragedy like i don't
think we've witnessed since
world war ii whoa
whoa that's crazy what's going on no
they're bombing you know in florida
we're in florida you had a building
collapse in florida on the beach as you
know through
bad structural engineering or
rust or something a lot of people were
killed in that building
he's bombing much bigger buildings
and they're collapsing and then they say
you see this massive building coming
down
all over the place
people are in that building
but you see the building come down and
then they say two people were hurt
no no
no when a building like that comes down
many people die it's not two people are
hurt but
is that a thing that that the
there's a suspicion we don't know the
real
toll of the building collapse in surf
side florida is i didn't even know that
that was a thing we don't there who's
lying about that is that a thing i've
never heard that before coming down all
over and they're being blown to pieces
and so we had a
a case in florida as you know on the
shore where a building collapsed for
totally different reasons oh he's saying
in ukraine they're lying about the
number it's not even clear which
building he's talking about
but it collapsed well buildings are
collapsing now in ukraine and there are
tens of thousands of people being killed
and nobody's reporting it what is that
now is that true because there's a lot
of right-wingers saying
the deaths are being overstated in
ukraine there's no evidence for that but
trump now says that they're being
understated
the press is trying to gloss it over
what the hell is he talking about
and i think if
putin is successful in taking over
ukraine
uh depending on what your definition of
success is because you know potentially
millions of people are going to die and
it could lead to third world war by the
way it could lead to a third world war
i think that's crazy i think what is
going on now that's crazy
is a direct reflection on the obama
administration
oh god
um
we're going to skip forward a little bit
more it's
they they barely move from
he's talking about 10 things at once and
yet
they also haven't moved at forward at
all um jack asked will i live stream the
democratic primary debate for
pennsylvania senate on april 3rd
probably not because i'm traveling april
4th
and april 3rd i have a bunch of
recording and things to get done in
advance of my trip so unfortunately i
probably can't do that one let's uh
let's let's keep going but if you
criticize biden
which we're doing because again
this
war
this ukrainian disaster should never
ever have happened
and it wouldn't have happened but yeah
we're definitely not scared of that
because we're used to it i think that's
why we're here like you said dana
respects us people respect us because we
never really gave a [ __ ] about it
the the place where you want to go is
for to people who don't give a [ __ ]
that's exactly who you want to be
talking to and that's who that's that's
why dana white loves them so much this
is now i'm sorry
big time i think even when we met you
even when we met you before when dana
brought us on air force one with you
even just us posting that we got a lot
of flack but i mean we don't really care
and you get a lot of love too by
we got a little fly from don they got a
little flag from the trees i think we'd
get more black for doing something with
biden we would well you know in our fan
base if we did something with biden our
family he would lose so many well yeah i
mean that obviously that's true
differences
they wouldn't try and destroy you
you let's see how you react i mean i'm
just saying i'm done big times i made it
is big time i want to see big time and
don't apologize though don't apologize
when they come at you
please don't apologize to be fair i
think we'd it's not like we're i mean we
support you and stuff but is this the is
this the victimization part where they
now they're going to spend 10 minutes
saying the fact that we did this
interview we're they're going to try to
cancel us they're going to try to do it
with our platform we would have someone
from the other side too first of all
but they would be getting but
why does everybody talk at once too
we have a very very very successful
podcast because we bring in everybody
we're not biased anyways shape or form
we like to sit down with people what do
you mean they said they support him and
that they love him and they were on air
force one with him what are they talking
about people they're involved in really
big things are happening in the world
today but the other side wouldn't sit
down
the other side has not showed us respect
like you guys have which is amazing i'll
talk to these guys anytime what's he
talking about they that's the difference
they may sit down but what they will do
is they will censor you exactly they
will do things to you that you would not
have believed because we don't have a
free press no in theory you should be
able to talk about what do you mean we
don't have a what
they just say no we don't have a free
press what's he talking about what do
you mean we don't have a free press
trump's the guy who wanted to control
the press and kick out journalists what
do i mean we don't have a free press
thankfully we still mostly do
despite trump's best efforts as
president anything and you argue back
and forth and the public will my career
my career is kind of already going this
way well no it
your career might go way up
but you may be without a platform or you
may be without whatever it is they will
be vicious you watch and i just want to
see how you your young smart guys i want
to see how you handle it well we won't
let you down but you will be hit
maybe you won't donald well the good
news is can i if i if worst case
scenario i used to caddy at a golf club
can i caddy absolutely i'd love to have
you could be mike eddy anytime he's sure
anytime uh yeah but donald when you talk
about like power and stuff like that
what's more like powerful to you being
the president or being a
multi-billionaire like
oh my god
wow
wow
that's almost just this is all too much
yeah but donald like uh what's more
powerful
i actually let's let's see what he
answers
owning real estate and like what's your
opinion on that
in the history of our country
nothing like me has ever happened i
don't say that
now we're now we're getting to
that is right sir
we have never seen anything like you in
the history of our country now now i
think we're on the same page now i think
we're on the same page
you know you've never had a business i
agree with you yeah it was i think 93
politicians became president and seven
percent generals so you had soldiers and
you had politicians there's never been
an outsider
likewise nobody's ever been treated as
badly as i have by the fact news media
by you know everything and we do our own
fighting back and all but i mean if you
look at their approval rating they're by
the way notice he's not even answering
the question he was asked
what where did you feel most powerful as
a multi-billionaire real estate guy or
as president he's not even answering the
question like it's it's almost like he
doesn't even really get the question it
used to be like through the roof because
nobody knew how corrupt they were what
do we think does he ever answer the
question or does he never answer the
question what do you guys think
will he actually give an answer
everybody says no for the most part
one person says yes all right let's see
and now it's i think it's lower than
congress the media's
which is pretty hard i think it's lower
than congress but um
i will say this in just an ending i will
say this he's wrapping the interview i'm
going to be watching you guys
[Laughter]
guys the question was
where did you feel that you had more
power as president of the united states
or as multi-billionaire real estate guy
it did he does he not like the question
does he not understand the question did
he forget the question it's it's
is it adhd i don't even know
i'm going to see how you handle it
right i hope i don't have to say i told
you so but what i did say to people
like merkel is don't do it and it turned
out to be true they did have one story
about that today very interesting
obviously the question's idiotic i agree
with you guys but it's just he didn't
even answer it i told her you're making
a terrible i used to fight with her over
it the pipeline do you think these guys
know who merkel is because i said they
own your country once you do it
but we're now forcing germany and japan
to become major powers
militarily and there are a lot of people
including me that say that might not be
a very good idea be careful what you
wish for
and with that it's been a great honor
one more thing i like trump ending the
interview that's cool i heard you're
becoming quite the dj here
at mar-a-lago i heard you're spinning
you dj would you believe it
i love music
i have an aptitude for music
oh my god i have an aptitude for music
that is just too much that is just too
much
during you know over our lives we take
tests and aptitude tests and all this
i've always had a high aptitude for
music but i love great music does trump
know how to read music or play an
instrument
i mean just
anything
anything at all what is he talking about
so do you actually spin or not what do
you
i pick the ones i like
i don't want to spin i want to pick the
ones what's your what's your like go-to
banger well i have a lot of them i have
a lot of them you know a song that does
get people moving though you know play
beautiful okay what song is he gonna say
what song is he gonna say guys i have no
idea is he gonna say ymca
i have no i what do we think
let's see what's i can't even imagine
what song he's gonna say i i love
broadway stuff and you know phantom of
the opera and les mis et cetera
uh you know what gets them rocking
why ymca
oh it's too much
it's too much the it's the only song any
of us could think of it's not clear he
knows any other song that is
unbelievable that's the best
it's it's like a parody ymca people just
love it oh my god i even have it on my
soundboard hold on where is it
here it is
[Music]
that you really can't make this up this
is i've never seen anything like this
ymca is a track it's an underrated track
do you know is it an underrated i think
so well it gets a lot of views i can say
but ymca
the gay national anthem did you ever
hear that they call it the gay national
anthem but ymca gets people up and it
gets them moving but we have a lot of
good selections and people love it when
i do it i genuinely don't know if trump
knows any songs other than ymca and that
proud to be an american song it's
unclear to me he is aware of any songs
it's the best song to like transition to
like ymca to what okay let's see if he
names it let's see what else he names
here now
maybe like maybe mo bamba maybe hold on
i'm coming okay what song is that what
song is that i don't even know what that
is
anybody anybody have any idea what that
is
what the hell is going on
sam and dave
let's see what that is
i've never heard of this before
like i have no idea what he's talking
about
[Music]
oh okay all right i know
all right so that's that's sam and dave
yeah man this is this is wild
[Laughter]
so 2 a.m
you go to ymca to hold on we're coming
and that just gets the crowd well you
know we just have a good time actually
we have great people there's been a
tremendous place mar-a-lago it's a
private club it's been an amazing place
what's your handicap right now in golf
so i'm a big time golfer yeah i'm uh
i've been a very successful golfer over
the years you know i don't play as much
as you really should play if you want to
become top top but i've been a very
successful i've won many okay he was
asked what his handicap is will he
answer that will he give a number what
do you guys think is that is that a
question that he's willing to answer
or is he is he not even going to answer
that
a couple people say he's ultimately
going to give a number okay let's see
many club championships which is hard to
do that's our major i've seen you had a
driver and uh you said biden couldn't
hit it like that
well that i can tell you that i
guarantee you biden probably hits his
driver like 120. well they asked gary
player the other night they said
who's the best player how many
presidents no answer man he he can't
answer anything anything were you more
powerful as president or as a
billionaire real estate guy no no answer
what's your handicap no answer i've been
successful at golf have you played with
he said i played with seven
who's the best player trump by far
he said he's at least 20 or 25 strokes
better than anybody else really i said
gary
isn't it more than that
but that's a big that's a big statement
but gary player is
a great legendary golfer as you know but
they asked him that question and he said
yeah trump by far are you like a [ __ ]
talker on the golf course you're trying
to get me no no no no you got to get the
you got to get the job done yeah you
just got to get the job so you just
actually you can talk yep and then you
can miss the putt and all the talk is no
good in fact yeah
so you still got to get the job done
right yeah 100 100 it's sort of like
when he insisted he was going to win and
then he lost by millions and millions
and then you look kind of dumb percent
and by the way i do want to say you you
look you look but when you see don he
gets a lot of [ __ ] for his hair and his
way he's like god like you look good
yeah i feel like he looks great you look
great i feel good so far so what's your
like mental regiment like when you're in
president like you said you slept when
you're in president that's a really good
question when you're in president what
do you do like six hours a night like
how do you
how do you do it you know what they're
acting like not sleeping a lot is part
of a regimen it's like no no not
sleeping a lot's bad for you i enjoy
doing it i love doing it because i was
helping the country i mean look at what
we did he's not gonna answer that either
right he's not going to answer what his
regimen is he's already just walked all
over the question
the biggest tax cuts on history rebuilt
the military biggest regulation cuts in
history you know that was maybe more
important if people don't talk about it
than even the tax cuts we had until
covert came the china virus came in
we had the greatest economy in history
we were doubling up we were going to
double up on china and everyone said
china was going to take over we were
taking over we were doubling up
and
then it came in and we did a phenomenal
job and then
when when i left this economy was
very strong again plus we did operation
warp speed which even even the
radical left biden tried to take credit
for it remember he said
man
i've never i've really never seen
anything like this let's see how it all
wraps up here
uh let's see just the last few moments
of it if it's not you
upcoming
who who should it be who do you want oh
we're gonna see you like desantis i i
get along with him great i was the one
that got him started he came and asked
for a kind of feuding with the santa so
this is actually kind of interesting
a recommendation endorsement
he said if you give me an endorsement
i'll win and i gave him an endorsement
he was at three percent
and after i endorsed him he uh took a
lead that was
not a beatable lead so you know he got
the nomination
did you see desantis uh did you guys
hear that someone said do you still get
along with him and trump ignored it and
now this guy's talking telling the kids
to take off the masks i don't know if
you've seen that video i haven't seen it
i haven't seen but it is time to take
off the masks yeah i agree with you so i
would i would agree if that were the
case
so thank you all very much yeah i
appreciate it mr president thank you
thank you so much we have to free up the
press in this country if we don't free
up the press this country's finished
right we appreciate it do some photos
yeah thank you
trump hates shaking hands too
uh man this is all this is all really
something so much
all right secret service is going to
probably kick us out right now but
guys full send podcast is officially
number one now i think it's safe to say
um subscribe yeah
wow
that is really something that is really
really i i've never seen anything like
that we're gonna have to clip this and
make it its own clip because i i truly
have not seen anything anything like
that
um
wow
uh
i don't even i don't even know what to
say i'm gonna need time to really think
about that and really think about what's
happening here uh okay i want to remind
everybody i am giving away
my
gavel we have adjudicated so many unban
requests that the gavel broke as you can
see
and i've signed it i've autographed it
and we will be giving it away
to a twitch viewer when we get to 100
000 twitch followers we're getting very
very close to that and we are going to
be giving this away we'll figure out how
to give it away if anybody has an idea
of how to do it by all means email us
info davidpakman.com
and i think it's i think it's going to
be great i think it's going to be great
so thank you for joining me we will have
more streams coming up very very soon
and everybody uh in ukraine we're
sending our best wishes stay safe and
we're going to continue covering what's
going on see you very soon